how much fun are you having working with
storm first of all the cutest that
little face I want to kiss her up every
day like she's my because she really
could be my daughter yeah she could I
think I'm gonna steal her didn't she
tweet out a picture of the two of you
yeah and she had my whole thigh out I
said storm I need you to put some lotion
on that leg before we start before
putting it out there on social media
funny because I told her this story but
my mom is obsessed and loves Love Jones
I never stop thinking about you yeah I
watched it recently and and she is an
icon for us so to be able to work with
her and her be so nice and and hilarious
and would give me little Tad bits of
advice it's just been incredible I love
her Siri called June Mom this is
FaceTime oh gosh E.T was on set when
they shot missing during the pandemic in
2021 and Mia said it was an opportunity
Mama couldn't pass up so it's been
really nice to just be here in LA
with no kids like laying across the bed
and no one hits you no one no one
bothers you and I can be naked if I want
missing in theater January 20th is set
in a social media world and is the
follow-up movie to the 2018 box office
hit searching that movie Bank 75 million
on just an 800 000 budget the whole
script has been kind of flipped and now
it's finding Mama it's finding Obama Mom
where are you guys
storm played June and her mother
vanishes on vacation and she uses
technology to track her down there's
actually a lot I want to talk with you
about you guys ever really get to be in
the same room I don't think so all of
our encounters that's crazy you're
saying that I'm just now realizing that
all of our encounters have been on the
phone before she goes missing and then
of course when I'm searching for her
she's gone
has your mom ever gone by any of their
names
what
[Music]